ils ont tout donné pendant ces jo au
pays du soleil levant et rentrer en
france vainqueur avec huit médailles
pour la région centre val de loire on
commence par l'uqam azur au badminton
il le sait il vient de décrocher la
médaille d'argent et regardez ici à
quelques minutes d'intervalle c'est la
médaille d'or lors les années et rémy
bull et s'empare quant à lui du bronze
en paracanoë lors de l'épreuve du 200 m
en kyle une jolie revanche après sa 5e
place aux jeux de rio en 2016 c'est la
première médaille pour la discipline une
belle médaille d'argent au ju-jitsu pour
sandrine martin et elle s'est inclinée
en finale face à l'azerbaïdjanaise sur
un ippon
ses larmes ne trompent pas elle regrette
la première place en cyclisme le blésois
raphaël beau gilet repart lui avec la
médaille de bronze au 1000 m contre la
montre
l'autre blésoise c'est marie amélie le
fur président du comité paralympique et
sportif français a remporté pour sa
dernière participation aux jo la
médaille d'argent en saut elle tire sa
révérence à 32 ans avec les à son
palmarès 9 médailles paralympiques on
termine par le tennis de table stéphane
molliens remporte la médaille d'or et
clément bertille et la médaille de
bronze le poulain qu'il faudra suivre en
2024 à paris c'est sans doute tiphaine
soldé numéro un mondial du saut en
longueur pour les moins de 20 ans